otherwise known as mirage danielle
moonstar is a mutant born with
incredible psychic abilities
but it's her leadership skills and sheer
tenacity that make her such an important
part of the new mutants
from her early origins to her latest
adventures this is the untold truth of
mirage
dany is one of the five founding mutants
to first appear in 1982's original
graphic novel the new mutants
ironically considering she would
eventually become one of the team's
leaders
danny is initially the least cooperative
of professor x's recruits danny is first
found in the mountains of colorado with
her mountain lion friend
ridge runner when dany's grandfather
black eagle shows up
urging danny to become professor x's
student she angrily refuses
as a native american who is well aware
of the betrayals her people have
suffered
dany is distrustful of anyone outside
her own tribe
but black eagle insists telling dany
that xavier served in the army with her
father and even became his blood brother
it's soon revealed that black eagle has
already sent a letter to professor x
and he wolfsbane and karma show up in
time to save danny from the mutant
hunting forces of donald pierce
sadly by that time the bad guys have
already killed black eagle and ridge
runner
dany agrees to help xavier and his
students but only to seek vengeance on
pierce himself
by the end of that first story dany has
begun to forge friendships with the
other new mutants
she uses her powers to help save sunspot
from the hellfire thugs who killed his
girlfriend
and in the final battle she even lets go
of her chance to kill
pierce in order to help save the wounded
wolfsbane
in 1983's new mutants number one dany
still
isn't feeling all that enthusiastic
about being professor x's student
after unwittingly using her powers to
reveal the horrific past of her teammate
karma
dany becomes shaken and full of
self-doubt in her eyes xavier had
promised a teacher to control her
abilities
but all he's done is give her a costume
and make her life miserable
unsurprisingly then danny is terrified
at the prospect of being tested in the
danger room
a high-tech training room that pits
automated opponents against xavier's
mutants
one by one dany's teammates enter the
danger room and each fails in their
appointed tasks
and although her teammates remain safe
through the ordeal dany is convinced
that she won't survive her round in the
danger room
so she flees the mansion before her turn
arrives after a heart to heart with
wolfsbane
dany works up the courage to take on the
same test her teammates faced
even though her powers can't help her
dany calls upon the agility and speed
she developed in the mountains of
colorado
and evades the robots to reach her goal
proving to be the first new mutant to
get the better part of the danger room
one of dany's lesser-known mutant
attributes manifests as her empathic
connection to animals
with this power she can sense the
thoughts and feelings of all sorts of
creatures
sometimes going so far as to see through
their eyes in fact she exhibits this
power before any of her other mutant
gifts
it's because of this ability that dany
shares a telepathic link with her friend
and teammate
rayne otherwise known as wolfsbane who
has powers that mimic those of a
werewolf
as early as their first shared
appearance dany proves to have a
stronger connection with reign than her
other new teammates
communicating with wolf spain while
she's in wolf form and later sacrificing
her chance at vengeance so she can help
her
their connection allows dany to calm
rain down during episodes when her
savagery takes over
such as 2004's new mutants number 12
when reign mauls another young mutant
when mirage is first introduced her
powers are relatively limited
along with her animal empathy dany
initially has the ability to create 3d
images based on someone's greatest fear
for example when dany helps the new
mutants save sunspot from the hellfire
thugs
some of those thugs have felt
wolverine's claws in the past
so dany pulls an image of logan from
their mind and projects it onto reality
making them think he's attacking them
again but that's about
it and even this power is limited she
can't just create any random image that
she imagines
however under professor x's tutelage the
boundaries of dany's powers expand
in 1983's new mutants number four dany
shows that she could manifest the image
of someone's greatest desire
when she pulls from a teen boy's mind
the image of him passionately kissing
the teacher he has a crush on
eventually she's able to empathically
produce images besides those connected
to such extreme emotions
she also discovers a much more offensive
use for her powers
dany can focus her psychic energy into
so-called psychic arrows
appearing as arrows of energy or fire
the missile weapons can mentally stun
her targets
or even cause them to relive past trauma
the new mutants don't have many of their
own villains and most of what you might
call their rogues gallery
is culled from the larger x-men mythos
but one notable exception
is the demon bear whose introduction to
new mutants marked a whole new visual
era for the team's stories
among other things new mutants
co-creator chris claremont
is known for dropping hints towards
future stories and letting them simmer
for a while
before eventually bringing them center
stage the demon bear is a perfect
example of this
as he makes an appearance in dany's
dreams in 1983's new mutants number
three but doesn't strike until the end
of 1984's new mutants number 17.
the demon bear is a dark and powerful
spirit from a dimension called the
badlands
who feeds on his victim's negative
emotions before she joins the new
mutants
dany believes her parents were killed by
this bear but at the end of new mutants
number 20
she is tearfully reunited with them
having discovered they were enslaved
and transformed into the demon bear
itself when they're separated from demon
bear by magic's
soul sword dany believes her war with
the spirit is over
unfortunately the demon bear returns in
a number of subsequent volumes of
x-force
to haunt and battle mirage while most
people associate asgard with characters
such as thor the other worldly realm is
also linked to characters outside of
marvel's norse mythology
for example a fan favorite x-men new
mutants crossover from 1985 called the
asgardian wars had a huge impact on the
x mythos
particularly when it came to mirage in
league with loki the enchantress
transports the new mutants to different
parts of the ten realms
and dany finds herself in valhalla home
of the honored dead
while there she saves a winged horse
from a group of hunters and that act has
more
significant consequences than she could
have ever imagined likely due to her
empathic powers
dany bonds with the horse whom she names
brightwind
and that bond makes her a member of the
valkrior
these are hela's valkyries whose task in
ancient norse myth
was to choose who would die on the
battlefield i think it's great that
there is a
an elite force of women warriors
it's about time while most of her
teammates noticed nothing different
about her at first
the asgardians are visibly intimidated
by dany
and the alien warlock attacks her when
he first sees her when she returns to
earth at the end of the crossover she
retains her connection to the valkyrie
and brings brightwind home with her one
of the results of her connection to the
valkyrie art
is that mirage suffers premonitions when
someone is about to die
in the form of death spirits that only
she can see hovering over the victim
when the new mutants are formed they're
students of professor x
eventually however xavier puts a
temporarily reformed magneto in charge
of his school
but in the field and in the danger room
it's mirage and fellow mutant sam
guthrie who lead the new mutants
despite having been the most rebellious
member of the team when it first formed
dany proves to be a natural leader while
her powers aren't always the most useful
during battle
this only serves to help in her role as
a leader since her lack of offensive
abilities forces her to become one of
the most resourceful and creative
members of the team
dany's a much needed guiding hand for
the new mutants particularly in the late
80s era of the group
in the 1988 line wine event fall of the
mutants
cipher is murdered and his death drives
a wedge between the new mutants and
their headmaster magneto the new mutants
need dany more than ever during this
time
and even more so after the following
year's uncanny x-men number 253
in which magneto leaves the school for
good to return to his villainous ways
toward the end of the first new mutants
ongoing series danny falls under the
control of the asgardian death goddess
hella
i thought you'd be happy to see me
after that conflict is over and mirage
regains control of herself
she chooses to stay in asgard to help
clean up the mess she helped cause
while she's on asgard most of the
remaining members of the new mutants
form the x-force under the leadership of
cable
and the next time they see dany they
think she's gone bad but things aren't
quite what they seem
dany reunites with her old friends in
1993's x-force number 27
but it's not on friendly terms calling
herself moonstar
dany fights x-force alongside her new
teammates in the mutant liberation front
worse still she announces her presence
on the battlefield by shooting one of
her psychic arrows into the head of her
old co-leader
cannonball four years later at the end
of x-force number 66
it's revealed that this was all a ruse
when she returned to earth
dany was recruited by shield as a deep
cover agent
inside the mlf she finally shows her
true colors in
x-force number 67 when she turns on the
mutant liberation front
joining the ranks of x-force soon
afterwards in the penultimate
issue of the 2005 mini-series house of m
wanda maximoff makes history by
stripping most of the world's mutants of
their powers
dr strange manages to shield a mere 198
mutants from wanda's wrath so that they
can keep their abilities
but mirage isn't one of them in new
x-men number 20
emma frost sends mirage home along with
the other de-powered teachers and
students
but dany doesn't sit around twiddling
her thumbs and in the wake of 2006's
line-wide event civil war
she's recruited to help train a new
generation of heroes
eventually however she's shown the door
when she proves more interested in
helping the young hero trauma rather
than turning him into a weapon for the
government
she would later teach younger mutants in
the pages of young x-men
with her experience as well as her
on-again off-again valkyrie abilities
dany remains an asset to the x-men and
other marvel heroes
however she doesn't regain her mutant
powers until 2019's uncanny x-men number
15.
earlier it had been discovered that dany
and other mutants were infected with the
alien transmode virus
and are subsequently used as government
weapons but when dark beast figures out
a cure for the virus
dany's abilities return along with the
abilities of her fellow mutants
the 2019-20 marvel comics line-wide
event dawn of x
completely revamped the x franchise now
almost all mutants live on the sentient
island of krakowa
where professor x magneto and other
mutant leaders have built a new utopia
as part of this event a number of old
titles were given a new lease on life
including new mutants in 2019's new
mutants number one
the old team reforms with most of its
classic characters
danny is once again part of the team
although it's not initially clear
whether she'll once again assume a
leadership role
after all magic is one of krakowa's
captains cipher is on the mutant
nation's governing body
and sunspot has led a couple of teams of
avengers since his last stint with the
new mutants
so if dany wants to be a team leader she
may have some competition
regardless it's safe to assume mirage is
happy to be back with her old teammates
again
particularly her dear friend wolfsbane
rayne had died from a brutal beating in
2019's uncanny x-men number 17
but resurrecting mutants is one of the
miracles of krakowa
and new mutants number one opens with
mirage's closest friend
returning to the world of the living
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one